the armorer on the movie rust is
breaking her silence
had two people accidentally shot on a
movie set by a prop gun we need help
immediately one week after alec baldwin
fired a gun on set that accidentally
killed cinematographer helena hutchins
and injured director joel souza the
film's armorer hannah gutierrez reid is
speaking out her attorneys tell et that
she is quote devastated and completely
beside herself over the events that
happened and it's important to note that
she was responsible for the safety and
handling of firearms on the set it was
improper for them to have guns on set
that were capable of firing live ammo
and it was inappropriate and unsafe to
have live ammo on the set
so these are the first two ways in which
this production went astray gutierrez
reid's attorneys tell et that safety is
her number one priority on set quote
ultimately this set would never have
been compromised if live ammo were not
introduced the attorneys also claim she
has no idea where the live rounds came
from quote hannah and the prop master
gained control over the guns and she
never witnessed anyone shoot live rounds
with these guns and nor would she permit
that hannah still to this day has never
had an accidental discharge the first
one on this set was the prop master and
the second was a stuntman after hannah
informed him his gun was hot with blanks
her attorneys say the production became
unsafe due to various factors including
the lack of safety meetings and they
insist it's not gutierrez reed's fault
earlier this week et spoke with firearms
expert steve wolf who provided insight
into how an accident like this could
have been prevented
don't bring guns on the set that you can
put bullets into
don't have live ammo on the set
and most importantly don't point a gun
at someone who doesn't pose a threat to
you so if you don't point a gun at
someone you're not endangering them
you're not risking shooting them
according to an affidavit obtained by et
baldwin was told by assistant director
dave halls who handed him the gun that
it was safe to shoot and he did not know
the gun was loaded with live rounds
santa fe county sheriff adan mendoza
said during a press conference on
wednesday that gutierrez reed halls and
baldwin are the main focus of the
investigation into the death of hutchins
only the armorer or the prop master
should ever hand the weapon to anyone on
set
because that person is responsible for
knowing the condition of the gun
verifying it themselves and then passing
both the gun and that knowledge to the
next person who should then also open
the gun
validate what they've been told before
they close the gun and use it in a scene
a source tells et that the actor is
devastated quote he is still processing
everything and dealing with a lot of
grief and shock
meanwhile no charges have been made in
regards to the accident and the
investigation remains open and active
legal commentator nancy grace spoke with
e.t about the latest developments in the
investigation and explained why the case
may take a long time to understand and
possibly bring to court
this is not a who done it we know who
done it alec baldwin but
was it his fault
i believe the investigation is going to
focus on
who handed him the weapon we already
know that for my witnesses it was the
assistant director david halls
who put
the ammo the bullet
in the gun
why did halls
reportedly call out called gun on the
set which means it's safe the santa fe
county district attorney has indicated
that this is a very complex case
and that is not unusual many cases are
very complex but the complexity of this
case revolves around the ballistics the
number
of ballistics ammunition rounds uh
blanks prop guns legit
real operational guns lying around on
the set
compounded with
so
many witnesses
you